wir begleiten die polizei auf einer
razzia das gebiet das wir fahren hat
eine der höchsten mordraten der welt
gilt dabei als ein mörder festgenommen
wird
es ist ein umfeld aus armut drogen und
gewalt wir bekommen die gelegenheit mit
gangstern zu sprechen und mit opfern
unterwegs mit der anti gang unit die
spezialeinheit bekämpft
bandenkriminalität in den cape flats den
armen vierteln am rande von kapstadt
wir tragen schutzwesten genau wie die
polizei denn der einsatz kann gefährlich
werden
wir fahren in das gebiet der fast ganz
un der corner boys banden
wir hoffen wenn unsere informationen
stimmen dort waffen und drogen zu finden
der zugriff soll im dunkeln erfolgen
abends und nachts seien die gangster
entspannter sagt der leiter der einheit
die sonne ist gerade untergegangen
an einem mehrstöckigen gebäude erfolgt
der zugriff
hier wohnt der kopf der sogenannten
corner boys eine gefährliche gang schwer
bewaffnet stürmen die beamten das haus
und stellen die ganze wohnung auf den
kopf
sie finden große mengen an bargeld
versteckt an verschiedenen das geld
stamme aus dem verkauf von waschpulver
behauptet die bewohnerinnen in einem
buch stehe wer ihr wieviel geld schulde
sagt sie 11.500 für waschpulver was soll
das für ein pulver seien der stadt den
schmutz von blut und kugeln weg 11.500
900 750 nein das ist von leuten die mir
geld schulden
wofür für das waschpulver und ich
verlange geld die bewohnerinnen sucht
nach einer erklärung für das geld und
redet sich um kopf und kragen geld
verleihen und dafür zinsen nehmen ist
illegal
was soll das heißen sie verleihen geld
leute bitten mich um geld sie haben
soeben erklärt dass sie sich strafbar
gemacht haben hören sie gut zu sie haben
das recht zu schweigen
sie müssen nicht beantworten was ich
jetzt frage sie werden nicht
festgenommen aber ich erkläre ihnen ihre
rechte
insgesamt finden die beamten 12.800
südafrikanische rand umgerechnet etwa
800 euro
das geld wird vor den augen der
bewohnerinnen gezählt und anschließend
in einer plastiktüte versiegelt die tüte
ist jetzt verschlossen haben sie
verstanden was ich ihnen erklärt habe
es wird eine untersuchung geben und sie
müssen nachweisen wie sie an das geld
gekommen sind
draußen am haus versteckt in briefkästen
finden die polizisten drogen kleine
portionen verkaufsfertig verpackt wir
vermuten dass das der grund für das geld
ist sie behauptet sie würde waschpulver
verkaufen in einem buch steht wer wie
viel geld schuldet da gibt es jemand der
ihr 11.000 rand schuldet für waschpulver
echt jetzt
während der razzia kommen nachbarn aus
den umliegenden wohnungen
sie wirken relativ gelassen es scheint
ein anblick zu sein der ihnen vertraut
ist
es sei gut dass die polizei hier ist
sagt uns einer von ihm
wir leben hier mit bandenkriminalität
und drogendealern das ist eine gute
sache dass die polizei ab und zu
vorbeikommt
das hier ist eine gegend in der erst vor
wenigen monaten kleine kinder erschossen
worden sind und das ist sehr traurig für
uns
junge männer provozierenden die
polizisten denen wird es zu bunt sie
stellen die unruhestifter an die wand
und durchsuchen sie auf dem boden finden
die beamten drogen wer sie weggeworfen
hat ist unklar
einige der männer sind tätowiert die
tattoos sind ein wichtiger teil des
lebens
sie zeigen zu welcher gang angehört und
welchen ramon hatte einer der männer
interessiert die polizisten besonders er
gehört zu einer rivalisierenden bande
er gehört zu mongrels gang
ich habe mich gefragt warum er hier ist
denn das ist das territorium der corner
boys er sagt sie hätten frieden
geschlossen
ich weiß nicht für wie lange vielleicht
hat dieser frieden einen
wirtschaftlichen vorteil wahrscheinlich
schießen sie deshalb nicht aufeinander
etwa zwei stunden dauert der einsatz
schusswaffen finden die beamten nicht
der leiter der einheit unzufrieden
ich denke wir haben viel mehr erwartet
wir haben erwartet wenigstens
schusswaffen zu finden
aber wir waren nicht erfolgreich das
kann viele gründe haben vielleicht gab
es eine warnung sie könnten aber auch
los gezogen sein um sich woanders
schießereien zu liefern
wir fahren weiter die polizisten haben
einen tipp bekommen wo sich eine
gesuchte person aufhalten soll
vorsichtig nähern sich die beamten der
wellblechhütte und schlagen zu ein mann
sieht dem gesuchten ähnlich
der vergleich mit dem fahndungsfoto
zeigt das ist er der mann ist ein
verurteilter mörder
er war auf bewährung draußen hielt sich
aber nicht an die auflagen für ihn geht
es zurück in den knast
im hinteren teil des raumes sind mehrere
erwachsene
einige stehen offenbar unter drogen auf
der linken seite liegt ein junge im bett
die beamten durchsuchen den raum sie
finden verschiedene drogen
nicht nur die enge in dem raum ist
bedrückend kinder
das berührt mich immer wenn 1 erschossen
wird
oder man einst in so einem raum findet
wo sie rauchen
das hat wirklich einen effekt auf die
kinder sollten so etwas nicht erleben
aber den leuten hier fehlt das gefühl
dass alles dreht sich um drogen ein
drogensüchtiger kümmert sich um
niemanden ihn kommt anscheinend gar
nichts auch noch die polizei
der nacht vor sich hin offenbar auf
drogen
daneben steht ein 18-jähriger die schule
hat er vor jahren geschmissen sagt er
die einsatzleiterin greift ihn an deine
mutter und ihre freunde können vor
seinem 13 jährigen bruder drogen nehmen
wie kann das sein wo sie ist das hier
mein onkel
sie sind der onkel noch ein erwachsener
der dass hierzu lässt die leute da haben
gerade gesagt die mutter hätte erklärt
das sei okay weil sie nur auf der
wohnzimmer- seite drogen nehmen nicht
dort wo das kind schläft wie kann das
richtig sein
wie will einer von ihnen ein vorbild für
das kind sein
sie sind der onkel ein erwachsener mann
der onkel verteidigt sich drogen sollten
nur draußen genommen werden findet er
nein soll das etwa heißen es ist okay
wenn die drogen nicht hier drinnen
genommen werden sehen sie für ihn ist
das nicht okay
der junge braucht schon gras sie haben
schon ein kind abstürzen lassen und das
nächste es auch bald dran
1 sätze wie diese hinterlassen spuren
das ist sehr traurig wir die wir den job
machen sind selbst eltern
man kann schon sehen wo das hinführt
durch das gespräch mit ihm vor einiger
zeit war dieser 18-jährige der 13
jährige der auf dem bett liegt in drei
jahren wird der 13-jährige an seiner
stelle hier stehen
das ist frustrierend die polizei
versucht verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber hier sind eine mutter und ein onkel
sie sehen es ja es ist ein teufelskreis
ohne ende
ein teufelskreis aus armut drogen und
gewalt im schatten des tafelberges in
den cape flats leben mehr als eine
million menschen
die townships entstanden zu zeiten der
apartheid schwarze und farbige wollte
meinem zentrum von kapstadt nicht haben
bis heute hat sich an den teilweise
katastrophalen lebensbedingungen der
menschen kaum etwas geändert
die arbeitslosigkeit ist hoch die
kriminalität auch hier haben die gangs
das sagen
die mordrate ist eine der höchsten der
welt
seit juli 2009 10 patroulliert die armee
doch das töten geht weiter wir fahren
durch das territorium der gangs ibrahims
hefter begleitet uns er kennt die gegend
sorgt für unsere sicherheit die armee
andere gar nichts sagt hefter unsere
leute brauchen hilfe arbeit bildung die
jugend was macht sie denn jetzt
es gibt nichts für sie sie können
nirgendwohin
manche von ihnen stehen morgens auf und
haben nicht einmal ein frühstück kein
mittag ein abendessen
stell dir einen hungrigen magen vor
was macht ein vater dann wenn da etwas
ist was er spielen kann wird er stehlen
um seine familie zu ernähren was
passiert und alles hat mit armut zu tun
wer hier aufwächst hat kaum perspektiven
viele jugendliche schließen sich früh
den gangs an manche werden unter druck
gesetzt
sie rekrutieren junge leute wenn du dich
nicht der gang an schließt dann hat das
konsequenzen
viele jugendliche sind dem ausgesetzt
das hier ist was sie jeden tag sehen
sie sehen keine andere möglichkeit über
einen mittelsmann bekommen wir kontakt
zu einer gang
niemand werde gezwungen ein gangster zu
werden sagen sie jeder könne frei
entscheiden
warum wurden sie zu gangstern
ich habe mich entschieden ein gangster
zu werden warum ich bin in diesem umfeld
aufgewachsen
ich habe von klein auf gesehen wie es
läuft jetzt mache ich das was ich
gesehen habe als ich klein war
die kaltblütigkeit mit der der 23
jährige über das morden spricht ist
verstört wenn es um rivalisierende
banden und so geht wird getötet
wir schießen aufeinander jemand muss
sterben
so läuft die gewalt das töten ist ein
teil ihres lebens sagt auch er ist
gerade mal 23 ich bin ein gangster auf
mich wurde geschossen
hier in den hals rein und dort raus alle
zähne hier wurden rausgeschossen ich
überlebe noch immer das ist mein umfeld
es herrscht krieg bei uns ein krieg in
dem regelmäßig unbeteiligte starben oft
kinder manche sind zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort
andere geraten ins visier weil sie den
gangs im weg stehen so wie er will
andrew sohn al kado offenbar wollten
dealer vor dem haus der familie drogen
verkaufen
avril erzählt ihr sohn habe versucht das
zu verhindern
eines abends will er nochmal weg gehen
er sagt er habe sein handy bei jemandem
liegen lassen und wolle es holen
der abschied fiel ihm schwer erinnert
sich aus irgendeinem grund hätte er
tränen in den augen
er sagte er müsse gehen ich sagte bitte
geh jetzt nicht die gegend es nicht gut
dann sagte er er müsse aber gehen sein
telefon holen
er fürchte jemand dem er nicht vertrauen
habe sein handy
dann ging er etwa 20 minuten später kam
jemand und sagte mir er wurde erschossen
andrews hat sich entschieden nicht zu
verbittern sie hat eine stiftung
gegründet versucht zu helfen
jede der frauen hier durchleidet
dasselbe trauma wie sie jede hat ihren
sohn verloren
die geschichten die sie uns erzählen
sind unterschiedlich und doch klingen
sie alle irgendwie gleich als der schuss
fiel wusste er nicht was er tun sollte
ich weiß nicht ob er in diesem moment
starr vor schreck war aber dann fiel der
zweite schuss
er versuchte herauszufinden was los war
irgend etwas in ihm sagte ihm er müsse
rennen
er wusste nicht wer auf schüsse
reagieren sollte und als er los rannte
rannte er genau zwischen die beiden
typen die aufeinander schossen die kugel
traf ihn in den kopf er war sofort
hirntot
der täter wurde zu 18 jahren gefängnis
ohne bewährung verurteilt um ehrlich zu
sein das fühlt sich nicht nach
gerechtigkeit an wenn er rauskommt ist
er in den vierzigern
das fühlt sich nicht nach gerechtigkeit
an er müsste lebenslang rein
ein leben für ein leben das wäre richtig
manche leute heiraten mit 40 er kann
auch noch kinder haben
marien ngz hat ihr einziges kind
verloren
ihr sohn war 28 als er ermordet wurde
es gab verschiedene geschichten darüber
wieder man ihn erstochen hat jemand sagt
er nachdem der mann aufgrund
eingestochen hatte stand er auf oder
versuchte aufzustehen
brand ist groß größer als ich doch der
mann fasste ihn von hinten bei den
hüften zog ihm die jacke über den kopf
und stach weiter zu sich das
vorzustellen ist so grausam dass grant
sich nicht wehren konnte und ich habe
noch immer keine antwort auf die frage
warum man ihn getötet hat manchmal finde
ich frieden wissend dass er nicht
zurückbekommt manchmal ist es sehr
schwer damit umzugehen dass er nie
wieder zurück kommt dass ich nie wieder
seine stimme hören werde nie wieder ein
kind hören werde wie es mit mami nennt
so wie er mich mami genannt hat einige
der täter sind noch immer auf freiem fuß
ich hoffe und bete dass die
gerechtigkeit siegen wird für alle
kinder die ihr leben in den cape flats
verlieren
all die unschuldigen die kleinen kinder
gerechtigkeit die regierung muss etwas
tun denn so kann es nicht weitergehen
er will darauf nicht machen
das system hat an uns versagt sagte sie
versucht die situation in ihrem umfeld
selbst zu verbessern
april hat aus eigenen mitteln und
spenden eine tafel organisiert jeden tag
kommen etwa 200 menschen
dabei sieht sie vor allem nach den
jungen männern
das hatte ihr sohn sich immer gewünscht
er war sehr leidenschaftlich was die
jungen männer angeht er sagte immer lass
mich nicht fallen wenn wir miteinander
sprachen sagte er lasst mich nicht
fallen sei eine stimme für die jungs
genau das versucht er will
sie geht auf die jungen männer zu wenn
ich diese jungen sehe spreche ich sie an
ich frage sie bist du bereit wenn du
hilfe brauchst ich kann dir was
empfehlen ich networker viel wir können
nicht alles alleine schaffen
aber allein der menschliche kontakt
ihnen zu sagen dass es hoffnung gibt das
hilft also spreche ich mit ihnen und
ermutige sie
ich erzähle ihnen dass sich jungs
gesehen habe die es geschafft haben
damit sie wissen dass sie nicht aufgeben
müssen
apple bietet hilfe sie sucht nach wegen
aus der gewalt wir können nicht jeden
retten sagt sie uns zum abschied aber
vielleicht einen nach dem anderen